cet après-midi à l'Assemblée nationale
et un examen qui pourrait tourner cours
puisqu'il y a ce qu'on appelle une
motion de rejet qui a été déposée par
les opposition pour qu'on comprenne bien
Alex en quoi ça consiste une motion de
rejet et quelles peuvent en être les
conséquences et bien cet après-midi
avant le début de l'examen de ce projet
de loi immigration les députés
écologistes vont défendre cette motion
de rejet du projet loi une motion qui va
être soumise au vote des députés et si
elle elle n'obtient pas la majorité des
suffrages et bien elle est rejeté et
l'examen du projet de loi immigration
pourra alors commencer mais si cette
motion de rejet est adoptée il y a alors
plusieurs scénarios possibles d'abord le
projet de loi immigration est renvoyé
directement au Sénat pour une seconde
lecture car on le rappelle les sénateurs
ont déjà examiné une première fois ce
projet de loi immigration c'était en
novembre second scénario 2ème scénario
le gouvernement peut convoquer une
commission mixte paritaire c'est-à-dire
la réunion de SEP députés se sénateurs
pour se mettre d'accord sur une version
commune de ce projet de loi immigration
ou encore troisème scénario et bien le
ministre de l'Intérieur le gouvernement
pourrait décider de retirer ce projet de
loi immigration mais ce serait alors un
aveu d'échec singlant pour l'exécutif
alors Alex quon sa qui va voter cette
motion de rejet du texte dans
l'opposition alors les groupes de gauche
de l'assemblée de laanupes vont voter
cette motion de rejet sans surprise mais
pour qu'elle soit adoptée il faut les
voix des députés les républicains et du
RN le groupe de Marine Le Pen va
annoncer son vote sa décision
aujourd'hui tout comme les députés les
républicains il y a jour de
l'incertitude on va écouter l'R
geoffroid dididier qui était ce matin
sur notre plateau il y aura une décision
collective collégiale qui sera prise cet
après-midi mais il y a une chose qui est
certaine c'est que ce texte dans sa
version de la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale ne nous convient
pas il ne n convient pas parce qu'il a
détricoté méthodiquement la version qui
était tout à fait convenable qui était
celle qui avait été obtenue par la
majorité de droite au Sénat elle ne nous
convient pas donc nous verrons bien s'il
y a une une motion de rejet qui qui est
adoptée ou pas en tout cas le ministre
de l'Intérieur géralde Darmanin
n'imagine pas une alliance des
oppositions pour rejeter ce texte sans
débat on va l'écouter c'était ce matin
chez nos confrères de C news ce sera un
dénis de démocratie que de pas débattre
de l'immigration parce que c'est quoi la
moisson de rejet c'est le rejet du débat
c'estd que les oppositions qui ne
pensent pas du tout pareil les Verts qui
vont porter cette motion de rejet comme
les fi bah ils sont pour la
régularisation totale des sans papiers
ils sont contre pour lutter contre les é
les étrangers délinquants les expulser
peut-être ils sont dans un champ
radicalement différent bien sûr de ce
qu'on pense et radicalement de ce que
pense leslr par exemple bah eux c'est
normal qu'ils veulent pas débattre de
l'immigration ça les dérange mais les LR
ou le RN ce serait quand même très très
particulier qu'on ne puisse pas à
l'Assemblée nationale pendant 15 jours
débattre d'un sujet qui passionne les
Français qui soit pour ou qui soit
contre le projet du gouvernement et en
tout cas face à cette incertitude du
vote sur la motion de rejet et bien la
première ministre ellisabeth barn a
décidé d'annuler aujourd'hui tous les
déplacements ministériels pour que le
député de la majorité présidentielle ne
soit pas mobilisé sur le terrain en
circonscription pour accompagner des
ministre et qu'il soit bien présent cet
après-midi dans l'hémicycle pour voter
contre cette motion de rejet ouais
est-ce que c'est signe d'une certaine
fébrilité dans le Gouvernement sur ce
qui va se passer cet après-midi pour le
moins oui ben je pense qu'il y a une
fibrilité dans tous les dans tous les
groupes hein à part peut-être à gauche
où il y a une attitude qui est hostile à
à ce à ce à ce texte
euh là où c'est assez intéressant de
regarder ce qui se passe c'est à
l'intérieur des LR où il y a une
division
euh qui est à mon avis mortifère depuis
pas mal d'années parce que c'est pas
uniquement sur ce texte là mais ça
continue à à montrer les divisions de
cette ce parti politique qui n'en est
peut-être plus un d'ailleurs et puis à
l'intérieur de la majorité bah la
majorité elle est divisée aussi elle est
contre elle est très très divisée euh
puceque que vous avez quand même
beaucoup de de de
députés qui seraient susceptible de de
dénoncer cette ce ce ce texte parce que
il n'irait pas assez loin et puis
d'autres qui sont dans une position
contraire qui va être l'arbitre du jeu
peut-être le rassemblement national qui
maintenant donne le l de la politique il
donne le l de la politique sur le fond
mais il le donne aussi sur la forme donc
on va voir cet après-midi ça risque
d'être assez chaud ouais Catherine c'est
c'est le RN qui va arbitrer les débats
cet après-midi euh enfin en tout cas
c'est ce qu'ils prétendent pouvoir faire
puisque oui oui ils sont nombreux 85
députés et il n pas encore ils n'ont pas
encore donné leur décision je moi je
note d'abord je voudrais dire une chose
par rapport à ce qu'a dit Gérald
Darmanin parce que il continue sa
croisade pour dire que la fi l'anupes
est en dehors de l'arc républicain et là
il raconte une fake news ce n'est pas
vrai que l'anupes et la fi soi pour la
régularisation de tous les 100 papiers
le texte est tout à fait clair d'accord
des de tous les groupes de l'anupès
c'est la régularisation des sans papier
au travail des travaill sans papier et
pas de tous les sans papier donc nous ne
sommes pas du côté de la gauche face à
des gens qui sont totalement
irresponsables et qui voudrai qu'on
ouvre les frontières et qu'on disent
vient qui veut et et bienvenu donc ce
n'est pas ils veulent que l'article 3
aille plus loin et régularise tous les
travailleurs sans exactement donc ce
n'est pas du tout ce que dit Gérald
daranin qui rejette comme ça du côté des
irresponsables et à la limite en dehors
du champ républicain comme on aime
beaucoup le dire par ailleurs comme vous
venez de le dire c'est que en effet du
coup il se met dans les mains je veux
dire de du rassemblement national qui en
fait a le dernier mot sur ces sujetsl on
se souvient que cette loi n'était pas
prévue je me souviens pas que quand
Emmanuel Macron était candidat à
l'élection présidentielle il est annoncé
cette loi en aucune façon et d'ailleurs
c'est a tellement été hésitant qu'un
jour on savait pas s'il y aurait une loi
ou deux lois s'il y aurait une loi tout
simplement c'està dire qu'il y a eu
beaucoup d'hésit maintenant cette loi
elle est ce qu'elle est véritablement
c'estàd en fait un Galot d'essès pour
jouer la répartition le le les rôles
politiques dans le cadre de la
préparation d'élection présidentielle
c'est ça le fond de l'histoire parce que
personne ne croit que on va régler la le
problème de l'immigration en faisant la
mu ou la me en faisant en jouant sur les
OQTF et cetera tout ça c'est très
marginal par rapport à la question de
l'immigration et par rapport à
l'intégration toutes ces mesures sont
des mesures symboliques et idéologiques
qui en fait servent à identifier où
chacun se situe dans le curseur de la
droite à l'extrême droite et qui n'ont
aucune efficacité pour vous aucune Jes
parce que tout simplement par exemple si
on prend les ooctf qui font partie de
l'objet de du débat c'estàdire les
reconduites à la frontière l'année
dernière c'est 4600 reconduites à la
frontière donc c'est 65000 qui ont été
prononcé 4600 donc on peut se dire il
faudrait augmenter mais quand bienen
même on passerait à la moitié ce qui
serait tout à fait exceptionnel parce
qu'on fait que on sait que un des
problèmes pour reconduire à la frontière
c'est qu'il faut que d'autre côté il y
ait un pays qui accueille ce qui n'est
généralement pas le cas combien même on
passerait à 30000 mais franchement
est-ce que c'est ça le problème de
l'immigration en France 30000 personnes
nous sommes 67 millions de Français donc
ce n'est pas ça le problème personne ne
vient en France parce queil a droit à la
à avoir des soin il y a pas une question
de signal envoyé c'est pour ce que c'est
ce que je viens de dire ce ne sont que
des signaux idéologique et que donc la
le seul enjeu de cette loi c'est un
enjeu idéologique pour pouvoir se
positionner de la droite à l'extrême
droite c'est-à-dire que c'est là que se
joue qui est en train de se jouer
l'élection présidentielle et Marine Le
Pen par exemple pourrait porter main
forte au gouvernement faisant un pas de
plus un dans le brouillage des repères
politiques parce que si c'est la loi
elle passe grâce au voix de Marie alors
moi je crois qu'il faut quand même
arrêter il faut arrêter une espèce
discours qui consist c'est-à-dire ça pas
été dans le programme qu'est-ce que ça
ça on s'en moque complètement que ça
soit dans le
programmece est-ce que c'est bah oui
parce que il y a un débat politique
c'est le débat politique c'est le propre
du débat politique c'est le fait que
chacun puisse s'exprimer euh alors moi
ce que je regrette c'est qu'il y a un
brouillage non
pas des des des uns et des autres le le
le brouillage c'est que effectivement
c'est les petits intérêts électorau des
uns et des autres qui prendent dessus
sur le contenu de la loi le contenu de
la loi me paraissait à l'origine très
important puisque un des problèmes
majeurs y compris psychologique
d'ailleurs dans ce pays où on nourrit la
xénophobie c'est que justement on
nintègre pas bien et quand il y a des
décisions d'expulsion ou de euh renvoie
à la frontière on ne les exécute pas et
ce qui aujourd'hui euh rend un climat
politique dlé teres DL terres c'est
l'impuissance de l'État et et
l'impuissance de l'autorité publique il
est là le sujet or contrairement à ce
que vous dites si justement plus de la
moitié pour ne pas dire 100 % des
obligations de quitter le territoire
é exécuté vraiment exécuté l'autorité de
l'État reprendrait des couleurs et
signifierait quelque chose aux yeux du
public ça en tenant le discours que
tient notamment et les filles c'est une
machine à faire gagner Madame Le Pen
c'est une machine à faire gagner le
rassemblement national ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et ça ça les arrange
d'ailleurs peut-être écoutez donc il est
évident qu'il faut avoir des mesures qui
soit efficace ça c'est la première des
choses et je regrette d'une certaine
façon que le gouvernement pour essayer
d'amadouer une partie de sa majorité et
puis faire passer la pilule et dans le
même texte
introduit cette une mesure de
régularisation des sanspiers dont je ne
dis pas qu'il faille pas qu'elles
existent un jour ou l'autre mais qu'il
aurait peut-être pas fallu mettre en
même temps alors la question se pose de
savoir si qui est-ce qui fait qui
renforce le Front national ou le
rassemblement national aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est de continuer de
polariser le débat public sur une
question qui les sondages montrent
qu'elle n'est pas en haut des
préoccupations non en haut non je
regrette je regrette elle est
elle est ha des préoccupations du des
gens qui votent pour éic Zemour elle est
dans les deux premières préoccupations
pour les électeurs du rassemblement
national avec à égalité avec la question
du pouvoir d'achat elle fait partie des
préoccupations majeures pour les
électeurs de des républicains plus vous
vous décalez vers la gauche moins ça
fait partie des des préoccupations et au
total chez les Français elle ne fait pas
partie des quatre premières
préoccupations donc je dis que
aujourd'hui on a mis en avant cette
préoccupation là on a mis en avant on
polarise tout le débat quand c'est pas
sur la BAA c'est sur la loi républ c'est
sur la loi immigration c'estàd qu'on
fait le débat autour des thématiques qui
sont portées par le rassemblement
national franchement est-ce qu'on est
est-ce qu'on est obligé de continuer
d'alimenter ce climat d'inquiétude de
terreur de xénophobie dans notre pays
est-ce qu'on a pas mieux à faire est-ce
qu'on a pas mieux à faire voyz c'est un
débat qui existe dans le monde entier
qui aujourd'hui est en train de détruire
toutes les démocraties bon je donc c'est
absolument dém quoi
s un discoursque de la part desons et
desus qui soit pas un discours de répse
à des inquiétudes qui se font jour dans
la population et je trouve ça absolument
irresponsable
irresponsableours pour ê éner commeends
discours comme comme parce que vous
prenez la parole et vous parlez
beaucoup les discours de Monsieur
Mélenchon et autres sur certains sujets
sont des discours qui me semble-t-il ne
sont pas très
on peut pas dire que dans le monde
entier l'ambiance soit extrêmement
positive et progressiste c'est-à-dire
que pour l'instant voilà et bien ce que
je dis c'est que l' alimenter la
xénophobie la peur de l'étranger et la
peur irrationnelle de l'immigration fait
monter l'extrême droite dans le monde
entier vous avez raison alors que nous
avons des défis majeurs comme celui de
l'écologie celui ou celui de l'école et
de la formation des des des enfants et
de la recherche scientifique comme
c'était le cas la semaine dernière dans
la avant dans l'actualité la semaine
dernière nous avons vraiment des choses
qui nous occupent plus la question du
pouvoir d'achat donc al juste alors
juste pour compléter votre échange
notamment sur l'opinion publique ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que selon les
sondages d'opinion et bien les Français
sont majoritairement favorables à ce
texte avec cette équilibre à la fois
régulariser les travailleurs sans papier
dans les métiers enention et avoir plus
de fermeté dans les expulsions donc il y
a une majorité de Français qui est pour
ce texte du Gouvernement et c'est donc
tout l'enjeu pour les républicains et le
rassembl national qui ont ces thématique
forte sur cette question de
l'immigration et bien de voter ou non un
texte pour lequel les Français sont
favorables car refuser le débat ça peut
être perçu par l'opinion ça n'en fait
pas une question centrale le refus de
laaba à l'école a été d'accord les
Français d'accord avec ça excusez-moi
excusez-moi je termine mon
exemple je termine je termine mon
exemple non mais ce que je
disogi habitu ça contourner l'obstacle
mais non le fait que les Français soient
d'accord avec ce texte n'en fait pas
pour autant un texte pertinent
nécessaire utile en ce moment voilà je
regrette mais je pense c'est vous qui
décidez contrario Catherine est-ce qu'à
contrario le fait que la droite la
gauche la majorité présidentielle ne
répond pas à ses préoccupations c'est
pas ça qui fait monter le rassemblement
national moi ce que je pense c'est que
la préoccupation que nous avons tous
c'est celle de est-ce qu'on va continuer
de vivre ensemble c'est ça l'inquiétude
or aujourd'hui dans les les raisons pour
lequelles on a peur de ne pas vivre
ensemble c'est on a peur du déclassement
on a peur de la pauvreté on a peur de de
l'avenir de nos enfants on a peur de
l'avenir de la planète toutes ces
questionsl créent un climat anxiogène
sur lequel il faut apporter des réponses
et c'est pas parce qu'on mettra 30000
étrangers de plus à la porte que on aura
réglé le problème c'est pas parce qu'on
réduira leur droit aux soins qu'on aura
régler en quoi que ce soit voire on aura
aggravé le problème de toutes nos
angoisses sur notre avenir et notre
avenir commun si j'ai bien compris
l'aide médicale d'État elle est pas
menacée ben non puisque dans le texte de
la la Commission des LO dép ça dépend de
la suite de l'histoire excusez-mo quand
même qui a été voté au Sénat c'était une
réduction du panier de soins mais avec
quand même un nombre de soins qui étent
toujours dansé d'Ur mais des soins alors
je veux dire on peut pas quand même être
absolument en dessous de tous les pays
européens tous les pays européens
accordent un les TF qui ne faut qu' ne
faut pas mélanger avec les expulsions
parce que ce sont deux mesures très
différentes les octtf je suis désolé
quel que soit le chiffre à partir du
moment où elles sont
exécutées c'est une victoire c'est une
victoire pour la puissance publique pour
l'autorité publique le problème de la
France aujourd'hui comme de nombreuses
démocraties c'est l'impuissance publique
et la défiance vis-à-vis des
responsables politiques qui ne tiennent
pas leurs promesses donc si on arrive à
aller sur ces deux terrains là et bien
peut-être que amélioration et qu'on fera
reculer les votes extrémistes il semble
que l'État a su trouver les moyens de sa
puissance pour imp
le recul de l'âge de départ à la
retraite c'estàdire que l'impuissance
publique elle est quand même tout à fait
à géométrie
variable th rel à la
sécurité ce que je vous dis c'est que le
problème de l' l'impuissance publique
cela dépend des thèmes cela dépend de la
volonté politique et de l'orientation
politique je vous je vous l'accorde
voilà donc il y a pas d'impuissance
publique il y a pas mais moi je crois il
y a pas d'impuissance je ne suis pas
pour le laisser faire il y a pas
d'impuissance publique il y a des
orientations Poti il y a des puissance
publique parce qu'il y a manque de
courage il y a laiss faire et il y a une
espèce de de facilité qui consiste à
cderer un dernier mot sur cette motion
de rejet cet après-midi qui a le plus à
perdre politiquement en cas d'adoption
de la motion de rejet ah bah tu V dire
celui qui a à perdre énormément c'est
géralde de
Darmanin factuellement c'est lui puisque
c'est lui qui porte ce sujet c'est lui
qui depuis un an et demi euh vu C a
voulu cette loi et doncement et est aler
ou et benr c'est la suite de leur je
dirais de leur décomposition
recomposition je sais pas comment il
faut appeler ça mais évidemment mais
sinon le vrai perdant si il y avait
cette motion de reest ça serait géralde
Darman il y a des chances qu'elle passe
pour vous Catherine la motion de
rejet j'avoue que je sais pas parce que
ce sont des vraiment comme on l'a dit
tout à l'heure ce ne sont pas des
considérations sur le contenu de la loi
mais des considérations tactiques sur le
positionnement pour préparer 2027 donc
en fait très très loin du sujet qui nous
occupait ce matin dans notre échange vif
et passionné avec
K